so thank you very very much for inviting
me to be here is really about Cornell
University years back I had so much fun
so many opportunities to grow here so it
was an excellent time I had it so it's
always a pleasure to come back and see
some old friends here so yeah when I
prepared for you today some of the work
that I've been doing these last years
trying to make sense of data so
epidemiology I'm I'm in the technology
so I'm the one working with data so we
we eat data we like data so we like to
analyze there so I brought this title so
made approaches how we can work with
combining data so different kinds of
data that's what we will try to show you
a different approach to answer some of
the questions that we have in plan
disease management when we have evidence
so that's the main thing of I'm gonna
cover this morning so the main idea here
is that to improve cleansing management
we need the research right we need to
answer some of the questions every time
we have new methods we never knew every
need evidence about the diseases we have
new diseases and new control methods way
and we need to demolish knowledge to
improve the way we apply those methods
so we need to look for the best strategy
to manage disease so that's the main
thing that we have been doing for many
years so what is the common way to do
that we set up experiments or we collect
data over time or we build some
simulation models but still we need some
data to validate those models so and now
we have the opportunity to have so much
data available that we couldn't have in
the past
so you know about this big data movement
so it's becoming more easier to
accumulate lots of data so it's
important to know what is the role of
Big Data and improving frenzies
management
I'm something here mostly about more
Applied Research okay but
it's important to combine so how we can
improve our methods using some of the
new methods some control methods and
then how to make sense of these data for
the needs that we have now take for this
season for the next years for the
problems that we that we have so that's
the main cycle that I tried to combine
here in a kind of a cycle so we have now
we have big data any kind of data so by
using sims or user input data like cell
phones you know you're able to to send a
lot of data to data bit with central
database so but in we need this data
from sorry Oh crops and plants and
disease all the management data is
important to extort to stay in in
percentages so the way we are kind of
moving today is using a decision support
system so we can get access to this
system
using our cell phone so we received the
information from the system okay but we
need these data are useful to conduct
conduct when disease management and
epidemiology research so we need to test
new products new methods and then we
need some more data so what we basically
do we are going to we are going to do
this for many years in the future are
the few trials so we need to test the
control methods in the field so what is
the difference between this kind of big
data that we have from sensors and the
data that we have from the few trials
okay all this information is going to
this system is providing knowledge so
the research will provide the new
knowledge that we need here to get an
estimate of the risk so the farmers the
decision are based on the risk so we
need to have a good good estimate a
reliable one of the risk to guide the
farmers and agronomist to take the best
decisions so and then we keep
accumulating data faded on this
things that we have been doing so it's
the site so over time we are going to
increase a lot the number of data that
we have that we can still keep using for
real applications to guide decisions and
also these data are going to be useful
to research trials okay so where do the
disease and new data come from so most
of the time the farmers will be
interested in the youth data so all
quality data so they need to decide on
what kind of control method they should
use to decrease the risk of heavy huge
loss that's the main thing
so where do the data that we need come
from they come from an expert opinion
sometimes we need some kind of
information about you losses for a
continent or a country depends on the
scale you have different sources of data
from the country and the region we have
some surveys that we can get access to
good few data and also field and triumph
class so this is the real the PDM
research as we do today rely on field
trials so it small plots okay most of
the tests that we do they are data on
its small plot small size plot
replicated once okay so is what is the
big data here so the big data I think
that we have now here we are able now to
accumulate and acquire a lot of data
from a single field okay but for testing
the efficacy of products we need more
situations so we don't need actually
data from a single field data from a
single field is important to take a
decision but to test for research we
need variability so we need a lot of
trials so the big data depending on the
on the on the perspective that we have
the scale for a few this k with the rim
remote sensing phenotyping we are able
to accumulate 3,000 data sizes is big
well it's from a single
you know that's the that's the point for
PDM research we need more variation in
production situations we need more views
so what is big so for PDM research maybe
50 fields is big enough okay
that's relatively big but for the Big
Data people working on remote sensor
that's nothing 50 is nothing it's very
little
okay depends on is the scale and the
objectives that we have here so for
testing a control method we need
variation locations and ears okay we can
have like a few years but we spread the
trials across different spatial
locations different situations that's
important so when we most of the time we
put out papers in integrated disease
management data on a few tries only two
or three so we need editors askers you
need at least two years right two trials
what is two trials mean in terms of data
it's just it's it's a small sample of
all the possible trials that we can have
to test in fact so it's really important
that we understand the limitations and
approach that we are we have been using
for years so most not all peer-reviewed
applied research articles we focus on a
small sample so we don't have many
trials and we have only four or five
blocks so the number of replications is
pretty low we test we are focusing most
of the time on them the p-values so is
there or in the NF in effect or is there
no effect so we are not interesting the
size of this effect so we want to check
if but there is the difference and not
how much is that difference so when we
review atop baited on significance we
tend to
use this vote counting so we count the
number of publications that reported a
significant effect and those that report
a known significant one so it's not a
quantitative it's more yes or no right
so that they can be complicated because
with trials where we have a look Howard
we cannot detect the effect so we need
more evidence so that's how science
needs to go we need to accumulate
evidence over time so a single article
single paper doesn't solve the problem
so we need more evidence when combining
in a quantitative or formally manner the
same weight is applied for different
studies with the different variations so
we different kinds of the precision we
just ignore that
so yes find the same weight for
different trials okay and sometimes
there is a bias I would say several
times there's a bias because people tend
to eliminate exclude there's known
useful data for example when the disease
pressure it's low we don't need those
data or we have a tendency to punish
what is good right so there's a
publication bias involved so we tend an
editor so we write well you don't have
an effect so it can't pouch this so we
need something that really works and but
that data is important to learn to
understand when there is an effect when
there is no if no effect so we just
can't just throw away this data it's
important that when we combine all these
having evidence we need to have this
kind of data okay so what is the new
model I would like to show you some kind
of a different approach that we are
taking we call these cooperative food
research networks so that the term
networks here means researchers working
networks to to devote to conduct
research that's aimed at testing and
kind of control method that we have so
it's a coordinated
so there's a central and we have a
network of people most of the time we
focus on one disease only I will show
you later some examples
the protocol is the same so within a
year this basically runs every year and
we have a same protocol the same
products it could be a fungicide coded
by control agent automatically so any
treatment of interest that we want to be
able to test the chemicals when we use
chemicals they come from several
industries so it tend to decrease the
bias because it sends only one company
and this company is very good to these
guys doing the fewer they are very
giving gifts or these pips of theirs
maybe we could dilute this bias when we
have a combination of products from
different different companies okay
that's the main idea if they are
independent they are not connected to to
the industry they could be but there
Ronnie tries for several companies in
not only for one in this in this case so
there is a control also what's kind of
there's some requirements for a
researcher or an institution to
participate in these networks we we
evaluate over years the quality of that
that they really have some ways to do
that and check and say ok you are done
so we kind of keep the control of the
researchers in this network new
treatments they need to be added new
products and some are cat because in
biology and things change and you know
it's very important one product that
works especially a fungicide then use a
tool for many years suddenly it doesn't
work well and why we know why because
the way we so this pressure of using the
same fungicide for years is changing the
biology of the population the field so
it's important to keep some of the kids
fungicides to accumulate this evidence
and then we can keep
the new or fungicides okay so what does
what do these trials they give to us the
disease and these people the researchers
they are intended to be very good in
trying to score this isn't in to provide
good quality new data what's being done
every year we need to put out the
response to the farmers very quickly so
we have reports every year a summary
from a single year in the form of these
bulletins or something like that and
then we can use meta-analysis to combine
data from several years so the idea here
is to increase the sample size okay and
we are going to have different
situations over years because even with
name depending on the disease we are
going to talk about slightly risk so
know that soybean in Peru is a big
business so there is very big there are
several countries within a same country
so it's very different
the the situations that we have in the
central Brazil the Central Western in
the South so we have a variation within
the same year we want to take that into
them into account so most of the times
we have networks so I'll give you some
examples this began in 2004 with the
soybean was so he was the leading
disease that pushed us to try to
organize all these products that some
companies would like to push to the farm
so we need to test in a common protocol
to see which one which ones were working
good because they were offering so many
things and we didn't know how to tree
how to manage so I mean worst by that
time and that was a huge problem as you
as you know so soybean rust was the
first one the first net Network and then
subbing white mode other disease of
soybean and then there's a new one six
years ago the freezer and red light of
wheat and the week blast
so you see important crops important
diseases so most of them most of them we
can't control without fungicide so we
need fungicides are really really
important here we have no other way to
to use something that we without
fungicide so cultivars for headlight
they work but they don't work well
without a website so there are so many
questions here and in over time what we
did was to okay the outcomes of this
network is to produce the yearly summary
updates the farmers quickly and this the
analysis that is done within the same
report is based on trial pages so they
don't do a meta-analysis in this case
here so I proposed that week we should
move over and then combine is as soon as
we had like the mean what three or four
years it's a good number to have a
variation in on these effects that we
should use made analysis so we have we
can increase the sample size okay
we don't the focus now is on the effect
size it's the mean difference or
management we say control advocacy how
much disease is the reduce it compare
relative to a check treatment so that's
the difference when we do the
traditional analysis we compare the
means so the treatment means and so we
don't focus on the significance we don't
focus on the difference so here's a more
logical I think effect size for us we
want to know how much you'll increase
relative to a check or a new product
increases yield relatively to another
fungicide so that's the most important
question I think more practical why
instead of 10 okay there is the
difference but okay and so on okay
the simply variance is a weight so the
tomato and Ellis I'm not sure you are
aware about it so it's a it
is an average weighted average so we
trust more in trials where the
variability is lower so to have a more
precise estimate we need to increase the
sample size right so we tend to trust
more and tries where the sample size is
higher and the precision is higher so
that's how is not a simple average so
there are so many complicated models I'm
not gonna go into those details all the
mathematical I'm just going to skip that
now but I'll try to explain it very
briefly we calculate this summary effect
but not only the summary effect it's not
I mean in our case the main effect means
nothing because we have a lot of
variation you have a lot of situations
that we you want that the best estimate
for the situation that we have like low
disease high disease pressure and when
the disease occurs early in the season
or late in the season so we have so many
variation that it's important to
calculate got all of them a fact so more
information we have about the trials we
can classify or have this method data
associated with each trial and then we
can test the fact of the mod moderators
so we group trials according to the
these factors that we need to assess
there for their fact so very simply way
this is a classic plot made an analysis
plot it's called a forest plot so here's
the idea is to show you that we have
five stories over different ears so the
first three showed that we had no no
effect for the odds ratio it should be
to have a significant impact it should
be greater than one so we have three
that did not show in a fact they because
you see the simple version is pretty
large so the size of the is the the
square means
variation is large so we can affect that
we can see page on the mean okay
so increasing the sample size is the
hypothetical date is not is the
fictional day just to explain to you the
benefits of using this so two studies
showed the fact one which was very
similar to this one so combining all
these evidence and we calculated the the
meta-analysis effect size 2.2 so there
is a real way that when we combine all
these evidence and this is the
confidence interval for this one just
taking the simple average 1.9 because of
these two studies the precision is high
and they effect they have a greater
effect on our mean estimate okay so if
we would stop here
there's no no no effect call you don't
have the power to to find an effect so
that's the idea here
so for Plenty's management data for
maintenance is what are other sources
that we have so we have the
peer-reviewed articles or non
peer-reviewed watts which one is better
so we have articles and reports by PD PD
mr and we have the raw the raw data and
we have this institutional reports so
which one think it's better for doing
for conduct this kind of work another
field like medicine pharmaceutical
social sciences they the origin of meta
knowledge was to focus on articles and
then they found out it and they need to
take into account for the publication
bias because we tend to publish things
that work so if we can get access to the
raw data then it's better so we want
the raw data that data from tribes
Edward tries to don't work ok we need
this data that's a chunk so get these
data from researchers is that matters
doggy that's very complicated here I
think not only in plaintiff management
but many other fields it's not so easy
to get this data but I have some
proposals that maybe we we can improve
this the way we work and share things in
and incorporate right well it all
depends on the the focus if we focus on
the Articles that's the most important
thing you're not going to get that but
if we focus that then that the data we
generate is important so to get more
grants so maybe people will change this
mind of a avoid the sharing so yeah but
it's it's good at both if we can combine
a meta-analysis from I can group them
and check if they fit effects idea is a
fact by the source so if you really said
well when I use Arcos effects so maybe
there's a publication bias
so the meta-analysis in plant ecology is
compared to other fields of studies very
linked at the grow so one two three
papers every year so it's something new
okay
people don't we don't have access to man
of good data yeah so many people don't
know how to work on this - how'd empower
meta-analysis work so we need to learn
more on how to use this but there's a
tendency there's a trend increases in
the future if we are able to put out
more data and get access to more data
maybe we can see more publications
coming up so as a senior editor of plant
disease I can I'm the one reviewing some
of these and editing some of these
papers and still we can see that people
still learning how to do it so but we
see more so people are there's a good
trend of moving from single tribes in
working more with the combining data
basically people working more research
and extension so many ex extension
faculty they have good Network now so
what are the main effects that we focus
the main effects are the treatments okay
we need to know what is the average
here's an example of you'd increase so
we have a different situations like like
I was saying the over effect and the and
the moderators okay this is the number
of trials and the call the correlations
between disease and new this is
mycotoxin we are interested in the slope
so how much you do we lose for every
unit of percent decrease or increase in
the incidence or any kind of measure of
disease here so that are the two most
important and using effect size in our
field
Akane's study one so what is think back
the question we had why is the impact of
white mode for brazilian side
requirements so what's the base
knowledge we need to calculate that you
need to know the impact the effect of
the disease on mute right so what is the
way is it know for our case for the
bridge no so it's not available so what
is how can we reliably estimate you lost
with white loss so we took this approach
the maybe sheriff was part of this word
Miller Delaney was a postdoc in our in
our group and he we stayed at Geneva one
year ago I think he was a postdoc with
era and he did his work we combined it
data from the the soybean white bone
Network for from the first four years
okay we had his data we took the data oh
this is very nice work because they we
had a table for each try so you could
get the data from each each table
and there's the number of trials so from
south-central north okay those are the
the lines represent a single trial so we
could generate a gradient of disease
based on the effect different effect of
the finder sites and then we have
variation in disease intensity incidence
and variation in used and then we could
know better with more confidence by
fitting a meta-analysis model we could
get this estimate with higher confidence
so more trials we have we tend to
decrease the confidence interval so true
average if there is some it's gonna be
somewhere between here so we have four
more years to include so this year we
are going to finish another a second
stage which is to improve more DS and
try to understand its variation because
you have a lot of variation among the
the trials that we could not find any
modern moderator that could explain at
least in part the variation of in the
slopes of this relationship okay so in a
very simple way for each year 10%
increase of incidence we have 5% utilize
relative okay that's the mean estimate
the intercept for the trials we had but
relatively we lose 5% yield for each 10
10% so now that we know this we can do
some math okay what's important Brazil
soybean huge area so we have this
information that 22% of the area are is
affected with soybean white mode so we
took the average of the other trials 43%
incidence is the average okay and
attainable will you yield we consider
3,000 kilos per hectare
when doing nothing if we do nothing with
the a loss for this level of incidence
will be 6651 kilos more or less 217
dollars per hectare okay
and now we owe a great disgust over the
country that's the cost of doing nothing
to control soybean white mode 1.47
peanut dollars which is a very high
number right so if we do something what
we can do to control some in white mode
we have the best fungicide 73% advocacy
so we can reduce the 43% to in 11.6 okay
you still have some lots so we should
have something that could be combined
with on your site try to decrease this
you'd loss when doing nothing when doing
something so something else is needed so
we needed by the culture we need a
better other methods to try to decrease
this for the 22% of the error factor so
we still have 386 million dollars of
lost okay so but there is a cost the
front side is not free right we need to
pay for the fungicide so average would
be like $30 for a spray four hundred and
eighty million dollars spam on fungicide
so when do we add those up
795 almost 800 minutes so that's the
difference of doing something in doing
nothing so by doing something we avoid
this loss that's a good exercise but in
fact we need more you need to by using
your by updating this advocacy we can
have the confident interval but it's got
the variation across so there are so
many things we can do by combining now
the meta-analysis estimates of
efficacy the utilize so it's something
that would be very nice to have a system
that combines and then we can move from
a regional management to a more
site-specific management so if you can
combine this information and the
economics in the decision support system
where the farmer can go to that field
and have some probabilities of this
doing doing something what is the effect
that would be nice I think so the case
study to how our fantasise performing
against I being west over the years so
the first network was I me was as I told
you so those are all the trials
conducted during ten years and we have
for every year thus these reports so
more than 30 institutions and
researchers over this this years we
conduct I study using ten years on so we
have four years more went to this work
so we have the simple averaging so by
just taking data from this disciplic
Asians we could just make the simple
part showing that for some groups or
find a sample the DMI the Qi
they they were decreasing especially the
DMI over over time so this is a simple
average you don't know the variation
within a year so the idea was to use
made analysis to estimate the decrees to
test there's a real effect of year so
here was a moderator in the model and we
could detect the significance and then
test and then calculate the estimate how
much efficacy is the quiz for every year
so we can predict maybe anticipate using
this knowledge for new products that
have a same they belong to the same
group so so this work is accepted in
in-plane disease this is felipe de la
Llana
he's a pianist I stay with Pierce Poe
and he did
a tremendous work and combining more
than 250 trials and each trial had more
than ten treatments so it's a very big
table to work with so our question was
are all funded sites declining over the
years so are the rate of declines
similar among them so just by plotting
this box plot is not a maintenance just
this describing the data that we have so
we could see that the Tembo Tembo Connor
saw the the disease level was increasing
over there over the years this is not a
relative to the two their checks just
increasing so just to have an idea that
yes but there's a lot of variation
within the same ear okay so the youth
the youth was kind of decreasing over
time also okay because less less
efficient the fungicide is so the idea
was to use the meta-analysis and to
calculate is it slope the average so we
have these we could see that after 2020
2010 we had this variation over space
across the locations but it still with
there is a general trend of really the
queasy frontside advocacy over time we
have different for different sites
wasn't wasn't the same so this means
that we have a lot of variation over
time so what happened in this case we
had laws of advocacy because mutations
were found in some places and then we
have the genotypes is spreading out very
quickly after one or two years to other
places so I I made this I have a very
nice plot showing every year the
efficacy the darker column means lower
advocacy over years so we can see some
kind of hotspots in some areas where we
know they apply the
number of sprays every year is really
high so we can't we have a still can
improve this model by putting his face
into account here so it's very
interesting as a model I think - - for a
larger region or so what is the
consequence of the bad management we're
doing so how many years we can use the
same fungicide or I think you see
so the fantasize we could see the
difference in terms of the reduction
every year was 88% vary from 2 to 8 so
differences among them and the reduction
in yield gained over the years because
we know that there is a strong
relationship between the control
advocacy and you'll return ok so the
cases is 33 that's important because 20
signs are no longer working for so many
words we know that some are but they are
more expensive ones so people tend to
use a lot the cheapest one
like the Buchanan's oh and people are
going back in the past and adding the
most inside fungicide does this work is
it beneficial so we we always need them
when we need them that's the question
that we then we have so more trials from
a network at least 3 years the common
mixtures amended with the among kazab
and then we could see just looking at
the box plots that seems that for some
case the disease was going a little bit
down every time for the treatments that
we added the Mongoose am you see the
gray the darker gray ones a little bit
lower but there is variation among them
and you'd also that you'll increase
there was some benefit but the variation
is still pretty large so can we combine
all these evidence and then maybe come
up with an estimate of the increase
gulf-front aside because it's not we're
not interested in the general so we you
want to know which fungicide
has greatest benefit when adding the
monk exam so there are some differences
so to make a long story short the most
efficient fantasise they probably don't
need ma come on cause that because the
unique prince is law so we need
microcell in those fungicides with the
lowest efficacy okay there are some
other things that we found out like
let's see this rash when the disease
pressure is 3i it doesn't work well
because there's when the disease is high
the rainfall frequency is higher so it
tends to wash off the fungicide very
easily so there are some kids when
fungicides not beneficial okay it
depends on the fungicide and also
depends on some of the situations in the
field so the 34 is a fusion with head
blight which fungicide works best in
Brazil we started this network tensely
different from the sides also and people
start to spray twice because the
industry say well we need to protect the
weak because you have the problems with
dawn we you need to spray more there's
another factor in Brazil because we have
so many foliar diseases and people tend
to spray during flowering at full
flowering in 10 days after flight to
protect the crop against headlight which
is many floral disease and the main
sexual side is that when we have flowers
but we have some foliar diseases 2010
time so so we were okay let's see if
this is been beneficial or economical to
do that so we conduct my my PhD frankly
we put out this paper in apprentices
this year we did this a kind of a fancy
Network meta-analysis where we combined
the evidence from so we have we can
combine different treatments we have the
direct evidence of one spray versus two
but we also have the indirect evidence
when we have tenma-kun also and the
check two times in one time so these are
kind of more sense
complex model it is very nice because we
can take into account the correlations
among the fund size be tested in the
same trial so it's a more modeling
approach that's that's difference but
the idea is to have Nora in many people
do separate made analysis for each
treatment that's what people do so they
test like t boo the increase relative to
the to the to the change in one analysis
people one here we use a scene at SEMA
model so and when you look at this data
we could see that there is differences
among the photo sites and the main
effect when it calculates the control
advocacy the Dybbuk wanna towards works
better compared to the other ones maybe
carbon is inwards a little bit close to
this but we know that in the u.s. from
the corners of it works well too right
so we kind of confirm it that you know
trials so 58 percent it's still low
forehead black so that's low but
compared to the main analysis conducted
in the US we are we are doing better a
little bit better because the estimates
are the low 50 in some cases a first
funder signs that we don't have like the
mixture of two trials also we have just
a single trials also we are doing maybe
best with the cheapest fungicide that
then you are doing here so that's the
main point does be increasing 100 kilos
payoff at second spray so efficacy is
not that much different in this case
applying just wants those higher higher
efficacy but when we play with the
fungicide price the wheat price and the
fine decide cost we can say we can see
that the probability of but not offset
of freakin even the fun side cost is the
same so it doesn't matter if we spray
this once or twice so it doesn't pay off
a second spray maybe it's not economical
okay and the case is 34 I'm going
quickly here one thing that people are
starting to use is a mixture of triazole
and the TMI and the Qi because of the
leaf blotches because of the leaf leaf
disease they say well we need a strobe
that but in the u.s. many other
countries we can't use a strobe we are
not allowed right to use or maybe there
is no recommendation to use that because
it's job has a tendency to increase
micro toxins so unfortunately so far we
don't have the data on the mycotoxin but
we do have data on disease and field so
the idea he was is really beneficial to
use mixture and other single trials oh
and also when we spray a trials or two
times alone compared to a premix also
also also also tries to date do they pay
off so it seems that we get better con
control by using the mixture maybe
because of Mexico it's a very good
fungicide so we are not sure about the
fact of the prior concert being is
really because they are mixed we can't
separate those but we have you'd gain
500 kilos more compared to a single
tobacco nozzle five hundred and fifty
kilos so it simply have a better control
a little better youth but when we add
economics here the less risky is to keep
applying PMI alone because the mixes are
more expensive so maybe we cannot offset
the costs by music mix it in some case
so it works but maybe it's too expensive
okay so the challenge that we have and
some perspectives so the raw data
sharing so that would be important want
to this is something that the English
this mod is not new so it's more
independent research but all the
industry they have this common
protocol being evaluated over different
locations than here so the idea here is
have something that is less biased so by
using a network of independent
researchers when I have a coordination
of these it has a control quality but
once people start to think that
extension plant pathologist is an
agronomist which we have a central place
where you can just deposit our data
there and we can get the credit for
doing that that would be very very
important because eventually just
putting out single articles it's
important if the data is available okay
it's important to report a summary
effect but for Mariners it would be much
better if we could get access to the raw
data so we need the funny so I'm not
sure I mentioned that but all the
companies they provide the funding to do
that
another single company it's a pool of
companies doing doing that so the
researchers they get the benefit they
get paid to do this and they also have
their names written reports in the midde
and analysis sometimes we invite them to
call but that because we I believe it's
important to give people that the credit
for doing doing something very important
especially in the trial in the network
tribe so can we think of like a gene
bank that would be nice I think that my
dream would be something like ApS or
some other and kind of a local we have
the PDM are publications but it would be
nice have something jointly or separate
that if all the papers should deposit it
that data I think that this is changing
now so many funny agencies they are
requiring us to do that to make a
deposit so that's going to be nice so
there should be a a good thing for
people for sharing for shiny plate so I
think it's very very important we just
we like to change this okay
so just before I finish this like to
show some pictures like thank Gary again
for the great year that I had here not
sure you even know Atlantis is in Geneva
now and Dave Dave schmoly was here too
you stand and go right back up Dennis
wait you know I don't know just great
people so I was very fortunate to have
the company of this great science
scientists skier so it's very nice and
when I got my job my two first speech
dudes they came here so they spent one
year in Gary's lat
so I was very very fortunate yeah he I
don't know so maybe some of you know pa
and Paulo they did a great job I mean we
had a very nice we set up a very nice
flame for so then one year before they
they came so there was a very nice time
they are doing very good now Peggy's at
Monsanto now it's his work on science
fighting guy so he's doing great in
Powys in bio tree which means the main
south america company breeding company
for wheat so he's doing greater and last
year we had Miller coming to Sarah's lab
so he was a postdoc that so because of
my contact lenses my joint worked with
in with the Sarah we she she could find
some money to bring Miller and he was
very keen he did a very nice work here
so luxury some of you know oh yeah and
nourishments - my my lab so none of
these is possible as we know without
people who do the really real job we do
only the talk and okay in Gary so and
all the networks all the colleagues that
trust me - that I hate could help them
to to to analyze these big data so we
can say that that's a big data record
you know implanted management's
okay
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu